[Música]
todos merecemos una tercera oportunidad
la primera me llegó por nacer por estar
por vivir la diaria aventura de
conocerme y reconocerme
la segunda que ganó llegó en ese momento
justo hace tres años
cuando mi papá antes de morir unos
cuatro meses antes de morir me habló
para hablar
por primera vez dijo la palabra
homosexual
lloramos nos abrazamos y todas las
barreras que habían entre nosotros dos
se desmoronaron
desde entonces puedo realmente trabajar
con la gente no solamente tolerar eso
que desconocemos
es en poder caminar y entender que es el
respeto
para poder yo llegar hoy aquí frente en
alto vélez a los ojos y decir
les acepto porque me aceptó
busco realmente todos los días a quien
darle esta llave para que juntos
trabajemos en la inclusión porque
respetar tolerar
respetar aceptar eso está en ti pero
tomar acción ese es el verdadero camino
hacia la inclusión está en nosotros
ese es el mundo donde yo quiero vivir la
tercera oportunidad es esta es todos los
días